Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This is the way. Both The Mandalorian
and Ahsoka have been setting Grogu and
Sabine Wren up as the future Mandalorian
Jedi, paying off one of the longest
running Easter Eggs in Star Wars history
next to the Knights of the Old Republic
stuff they've just been doing on Ahsoka.
So we'll break it all down,
If you're brand new to the channel, I'm
doing videos for all the Ahsoka episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
Those are getting teasers
for the Mandalorian Season
four probably by early next year too.
Jon Favreau Dave Filoni
will be doing a full season of that
before the big Thrawn movie happens.
Generally.
All this stuff
in this part of the timeline,
The Mandalorian episodes
book of Boba Fett, the Ahsoka episodes
are all meant to cross over.
everything that's happening right now
on Ahsoka is taking place
right after the Mandalorian Season three.
But during The Mandalorian,
they've slowly been showing
that Grogu himself has been going through
the steps needed to actually become
a mandalorian, a part of their culture.
he's already rising on the path
through their ranks.
The Armor kind of gave him an exception
to actually taking the creed.
And so that's typically
the main requirement for anyone
who wishes to become a mandalorian.
They have to verbally recite the creed,
take the oath.
But Grogu
hasn't shown he's been able to speak
basic tongue like Yoda or Jarrell yet.
There've been a lot of theories
that he can already speak, but the closest
he's doing to actual
speaking is just in his own native tongue,
like he's speaking Yoda's language
when he's talking like this.
that was meant to be him
mimicking Bo-Katan in Mando
saying this is the way
but in Yoda's natural tongue he's slowly
getting his armor pieces like a regular
Mandalorian slowly training in the force.
He's just not pursuing the traditional
Jedi path at Luke Skywalker Academy.
He's more like a soldier in the desert,
studying the force in their own way
the traditional Jedi teachings
are just one of many different ways
of studying the force The night sisters
are a recent example of another force
tradition that's very, very different
in practice, in the abilities.
Now, during the first few
episodes of Ahsoka, one of the new changes
Dave Filoni just introduced to
the canon
was saying that during the time jump
between the end of the Battle of Luthor
in Star Wars Rebels finale,
in the tag scene at the very end,
Sabine had been training in the force
with Ahsoka as master and apprentice.
They just clarified that the live action
version of this scene
that time jump during
Rebels was close to about ten years.
Way longer,
I think, than we originally thought
when they originally aired
the Rebels episode.
this scene in present day is taking place
just after the Mandalorian season three.
during the first few episodes,
David Tennant, who Yang tells Sabine
that she's got the lowest aptitude
for the force that he's ever seen,
and remember, he's from
the Old Republic
era many thousands of years ago,
and he's helped pretty much every single
Jedi ever build their light saber.
So you're talking many tens of thousands
of Jedi that he's known over the years.
what that means is that it seems like her
mid-Victorian count is super low
compared to more powerful Jedi
like a soldier and a can Skywalker Grogu
even Ezra Bridger, they haven't clarified
whether or not who Yang met.
Ezra Bridger I'm assuming that he did not,
but he would probably know
about his existence
in answering the other side
of that question.
If it wasn't clear
who Yang would also know about Grogu,
even though he probably never met him
at the Jedi Temple.
Because remember who Yang spent
all of his time on the ancient Jedi ship
ferrying younglings back and forth to ILM,
where they would find their kyber crystals
and use them to construct lightsabers
like that was basically his function
within the Jedi Order
for many thousands of years
Grogu, who never seems like
he got to the point
in his physical development
when his hands were just
actually big enough to wrap their fingers
around a Yoda sized lightsaber.
Like, even if they gave him a light saber,
he probably wouldn't be able to hold it
like he should be able to.
that was the funny thing.
When Luke Skywalker offered him
one of Yoda's former lightsabers, like,
would he actually be able to hold that
if he gave it to him?
I think the idea is that Lucas intended
for Grogu to keep that with his belongings
until he grew big enough
to actually use it.
not, he's left Luke Skywalker's
Jedi Academy and did not take Yoda's
lightsaber.
That just means that as he grows
more powerful and physically grows larger,
eventually
he'll construct his own new lightsaber,
which I think a lot of people wanted
this is also very similar
to the path that Ahsoka followed
when she left the Jedi Order.
She left her old lightsabers, her
original lightsabers behind, and again
eventually gave them back to her.
But she lost them again, left the last one
behind to trick the empire
into thinking that she died.
Just like Grogu.
She went for a while without a lightsaber.
Then she got her new twin lightsabers
when she fought the Inquisitor,
the six brother here in Tales of the Jedi,
defeated him, took his red light
saber crystals,
purified them to their white color,
and made her own new twin lightsabers
from them.
Grogu will probably do something similar,
will eventually find his own lightsaber
crystal make a new lightsaber,
but because he grows so slowly,
like if you use charting the timeline
here,
that probably won't be till well
after the Thrawn movies happen.
probably going to be pretty tiny
for a good long while,
But basically he's meant to be
the next Mandalorian Jedi.
Since TAA Vizsla over a thousand years
ago, the one that created the Darksaber
became a Jedi Knight before coming back
to Mandalore to lead his people.
Now there were many other force
sensitive mandalorians in the years
after him, but none of them ever trained
in the force or became Jedi Knights.
until you get to grogu
you announce the being Ren.
The only difference
between the two of them is that Grogu,
who is way more powerful in Sabine
Wren, was born a Mandalorian and Grogu
who just became a mandalorian over time.
There've been a ton of questions
about how they're handling
the Sabine character on Ahsoka,
but I think it's pretty clear to the first
few episodes.
Dave Filoni is just saying
that Sabine has always been for sensitive.
They're just really only exploring that
in depth.
Now, during the Star Wars Rebels episodes,
they kind of brushed over it,
I think, because they were focusing
more on the lore
behind the Darksaber,
the Mandalorian culture
and what was going on with Ezra Bridgers
force training
But at some point
after the Battle of Lothar,
just before the events of a New Hope,
Sabine would have started
formally training in the force, with Ahsoka
becoming her Padawan
in when we use the term Jedi
so can ever really consider herself a Jedi
during those first few Ahsoka episodes,
they specifically say that Balan school,
who also does not think of himself as a
Jedi, has been training his apprentice,
Shin Hatty, in the formal Jedi practices
like constructing lightsabers.
Her fighting form is more like
the traditional Jedi forms
balance school and Ahsoka
would have learned at the Jedi Temple.
So it seems like the two of them, Ahsoka
and Balan, are passing on some aspects
of the traditional Jedi training,
but not all.
They're very strict rules and beliefs.
Like most of the stuff
that they're borrowing
from the traditional Jedi path
are the practical aspects like fighting
techniques, basic skills.
in according to who
Yang Saben isn't a super quick learner
like Aniket or Soko or even Grogu or Ezra.
He was just trying to tell her
that she can totally become a Jedi,
but she's going to have to work
way harder than all those other Jedi
that came before her
the whole thing with Ezra's lightsaber
now belonging to her will probably turn
into a huge twist later in the series
when they reveal what really happened
to Ezra in present day.
I know there's tons of theories
about that.
I've heard in a couple of videos
about some mystery characters like Burak.
they wanted to make it clear, though,
that the light saber
ultimately belongs to her
now, regardless of what happens to it,
the next several episodes or what happens
with Ezra Bridger, he would have either
constructed a new lightsaber for himself
or he doesn't need one anymore.
And it will have something to do
with the new law that Dave Filoni
is introducing with this other galaxy
that they're calling Perea
the original home of the space
wells, the Pergolas.
If that wasn't clear, they were implying
that the space wells originally
came from that other galaxy,
and that's how they knew how to find it,
because it was just part of their pod's
normal path.
They follow through the universe
like aquatic creatures migrate along,
set paths on a regular basis
there are a bunch of live action
versions of them in the trailer,
so it seems like
we'll actually run into them
in the next few episodes.
But the whole point is
that Sabine is still a mandalorian, too.
Now, like Rogue
who's becoming a Mandalorian.
Essentially,
they're the future mandalorian Jedi.
still a little salty that we didn't see
Clan Ren in that ending scene
for The Mandalorian Season three or Sabine
Wren didn't show up for that.
I think that was mostly a budget thing.
But if we're talking about the future
of Star Wars here, even though
Sabine Age is like a normal human,
she'll grow old and die before Grogu
even reaches his prime.
Yoda was about 100 years old
when he became a Jedi master.
Grogu, who is in his early fifties Right
now, just based on the timing for when
Star Wars rebels happens to be in,
seems like she's around her late
twenties in present day,
so she'd be in her seventies
like wizened old mandalorian Jedi master
by the time Grogu also reaches
full size and becomes the junior master.
Now I know everyone's going to ask
whether or not
the two of them will start their own Jedi
Academy together in the distant future.
Because of what happens
with Luke Skywalker's Jedi Academy.
It probably wouldn't be till after
the events of the sequel trilogy,
And they did just announce
those new Star Wars movies.
They plan on setting ten years
after the sequel trilogy.
that would be when Grogu wants to be
would probably be training
a bunch of other students.
Unless Dave Filoni has some special plans
for this other new galaxy.
long term.
I think the Star Wars will always try to
keep Grogu around for financial reasons.
Mostly story reasons too.
Like he's going to live 900 years.
Like there's just so much story
to explore with his character.
Why would you get rid of him
so quickly? but.
I think the main reason for introducing
this other galaxy
is because just in general,
they're trying
to branch outside of the main Star Wars
galaxy like there's been trapped
in this main galaxy for so many years.
I think they're trying to broaden
the Star Wars universe,
like literally the term universe.
Grogu could eventually
just kind of traveling to the other galaxy
at some point,
having a bunch of adventures there
for hundreds of years,
and he's still be relatively middle aged.
practically Dave Filoni
and Jon Favreau, have been pretty clear
that they don't want to answer
those kind of questions right now.
Like we're not going to reveal
what happens to Grogu
who in like ten or 15 years even.
they don't want to explain
what happens to him
during the events of the sequel trilogy.
Even because that would kind of give away
the plot of what's going to happen to him
during the events of the Thrawn movies
to Generally just means that it's wide
open for theory crafting for a long time.
So let me know in the comments.
If Grow in Sabine
are the future of the Mandalorian Jude
I Do you think that they'll form
a new academy themselves together,
or would you just rather see them travel
to the new galaxy and have adventures
there I'll post my Ahsoka
Episode three video as soon as possible.
After the episode airs tonight,
be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for that video onto the link
as soon as I post it and click here
for all my other Ahsoka episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
This is the way!